hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
as you know we are not afraid
here at mindscape about getting deep
into things and today we're gonna get
deep into some of the most profound
ideas in philosophy you know we've
talked about philosophy before we've
talked to philosophers about pretty darn
deep ideas about realism about
consciousness about physics today we're
gonna talk about truth and truth is one
of those things you think well you know
maybe it's a pretty straightforward idea
some things are true some things not
true anyone marginally acquainted with
modern philosophy should know better
than that right of course things are
gonna get really really complicated the
analogy that I have in my brain is
girdle's theorem in mathematics kurt
gödel proved that if you have a
sufficiently strong formal system a
system where you can like prove theorems
and so forth using logic and math and
deduction then there will always be one
of two choices either there are true
statements in that system that you can
never prove or the system itself is
somehow incomplete somehow internally
incoherent it's not consistent and this
is a surprising result right you might
think people did think you could prove
everything that was true in a formal
system not true and in fact that lesson
generalizes to other ideas that we might
have about truth it's very very hard to
be formal and rigorous and careful about
what you mean by the word truth so today
we're going to an expert
Liam Kofi Breit is a professor of
philosophy in the department of
philosophy logic and scientific method
at the London School of Economics if you
want to know why the department's called
that Karl Popper was a influential
person back at the London School of
Economics back in the day so things Karl
Popper was interested in became an
entire department philosophy logic and
the scientific method we're gonna talk
about all of those things today liam is
an expert not only on the formal aspects
of what truth is you know there's a lot
of simple manipulation and proving
things and being very very careful and
rigorous that goes into this kind of
game but also the down-and-dirty how do
we figure out what is true so not only
what is
but how do we figure it out right the
game of epistemology so we can go from
this crystal clear set of theorems and
axioms and so forth to really difficult
real-world questions you know when you
say how do you figure out what is true
you might say well use the scientific
method okay well what's that right what
not only do we say the scientific method
is but how does it actually play out in
the real world how do we decide who gets
published in journals what is the role
of refereeing how do different kinds of
scientists bring different perspectives
to the questions of what is true and
what is false even if we all think that
the universe is real and it's out there
and what is true about it is going to be
objective for everyone the ways that we
get to that truth might depend a lot on
who we are and what we bring to the
table so there's a lot going on here
it's a wonderful fun conversation one of
the it's this is the last holdover from
what I got to do when I was visiting the
UK a little while ago lean was nice
enough to let me delay this while other
podcasts got into the queue so I think
we're gonna have fun here it's a little
brain teaser let's go
[Music]
right welcome to the mindscape podcast
hi Schon
I do want to mention for the listeners
that we're in swinging London and at a
university so there is construction
going on outside yeah sorry about that
listen that's okay the listeners are a
flexible Bunch by now they would they've
learned to accept things I thought that
we would talk about the nature of truth
and the nature of knowledge and the
nature of science and then with all the
extra time we had left over well but
yeah once you settle acknowledge truth
in science you know still have about an
hour left okay
oh so truth let me let me maybe the good
way to get this is to sort of say look
there's a way that scientists think
about what they're doing you know they
come with a model maybe there's words
like particles and forces and fields
involved and if the model works if it
fits the data they will say look I have
found some truth the truth is reflected
in the relationship of my model to
reality so what do you sufficient
grown-up philosophers think about that
picture of truth sophisticated you're
asking what the no class so there's a
kind of interesting feature of the way
philosophers think about truth which is
as far as I can tell it diverges from
how everyone else in the world thinks
about truth and yet philosophers tend to
think of themselves as only explaining
the common-sense view for what it's
worth my experience of talking with
scientists has actually been very
different the scientists tend to be very
averse to describing the results of
their inquiry as truth and partly
because I think they're working in the
background with more loaded vision of
what truth is or would have to be then
philosophers tend to be let me explain
why I mean so philosophical thinking
about truth as it's done nowadays
there's a kind of sort of classic
dialectic which for instance we teach
undergraduate students I teach a
first-year course this would be how I
would introduce them to it where there
was in the early 20th century late 19th
century debate between these kind of
stylized positions which we nowadays
remember as the correspondence theory of
truth the pragmatist theory of truth and
the coherent his theory of truth
according to the correspondence theory
of
truth truth consists in a relationship
of correspondence between judgments or
some sort of you know eight utterances
or written sentences or something like
that and the facts where the facts are
these metaphysical composite entities
out there so for instance if I say
understand examples the cat is on the
map then that is true just in case there
is this thing a fact out there which is
this structured complex of a cat and map
the relationship on that mm-hmm on the
cat actually being the thing which is
bearing in relation to the map and
that's the corresponds theater yeah this
seems like a not crazy theory so far I
think that would probably that's the
view which especially for us was tend to
think of as the correspondence theory is
the common sense theory of truth rather
the pragmatists theory of truth and one
the news I'm going to go through them
then I'll go back into whether problems
the practice theory of truth has many
different iterations there's not like
one canonical formulation is a famous
slogan is a truth is what's good by way
of belief and there the idea so I think
like truth true beliefs are those which
one expects to work for you in the long
run or something like that where belief
has a certain purpose which is helping
us orient ourselves and act successfully
in the world true beliefs or those which
consistently and systematically help us
achieve those purposes they allow belief
to fulfill its function successfully the
cash value of ideas was the slogan
though yesterday ago right is the same
thing it's like the things which like in
the end how does this belief play out in
my life in my action was it is it what
good is it for me in a scientific
context that will often be seen as of
link to empiricism where yeah there is
that true beliefs are those which sort
of bear out experimentally with when I
try and test them they don't end up
being wrong and so that would be the
pragmatist theory and they're coherent
ists theory of truth is a bit different
from both of those where the coherent
history more or less has it that um
true belief is a belief which sort of
fits into the maximally coherent theory
of the world smashing you had this sort
of fully worked out theory of everything
which was able to accommodate all of
your observations of everything you come
across a belief is true just in case it
would fit into that so very very complex
no doubt will always be hypothetical but
hypothetical totality of beliefs so I
said this is a little classic dialectic
released of stylized positions because
more as all of those have now been
abandoned like you'd you wouldn't find
you very well I'm just gonna say that
I've gone through believing in all those
different theories and then I landed at
the car of the coherence theory more
than anything else so now you gonna tell
me that I've spent my life being wrong
in different ways yeah and you know
that's just everything good right you
shone and humanist wrong about
everything but uh and me I guess except
the same eyes that you're wrong
everything I was right about that okay
so um the issues of course you'll find
sort of people who have more
sophisticated versions of the initial
formulations and so nothing ever dies it
just gets reborn and rebuilt but there
are sort of big problems with each of
these which make people a bit wary of
assuming any of them I'll go in reverse
order so for the coherence fairness
theory
typically the worry is just there's no
way of specifying a unique best theory
under them the problem is is that
multiple very consistent very coherent
for we can tell theories can be
formulated which would allow
contradictory beliefs in and now I have
no fact of the matter as to which of
those well I ever have to endorse true
contradictions or I have to or I have to
find some way of deciding between the
max coherent well to use I can formulate
and that doesn't seem quite right
because the natural way of deciding
between a very very consistent fairytale
and a very very accurate description
vote is that one of them is true and one
of them isn't but like that's now being
denied I mean the reason why it took me
so long to even entertain the coherence
theory is that it seems obvious to me
there's different coherent theories
they're completely different and what
sort of broke the tie for me was
thinking that well one of the things
that your theory needs to be coherent
with are your observations of the world
right and so that it's not just there
internally coherent there's some
external coherence as well
yeah I mean I should say I'm I probably
don't endorse the coherence theory but
I'm more sympathetic than most this is
just kind of the standard objection to
it that said what I think people would
say to things like what you just said
would be that there are actor always
lots and lots of ways of explaining my
immediate experience right so you know
classic reign in Tibet brain-in-a-vat
yeah demon deceiving me in the matrix
whatever and so the worry is that um
whatever things I try and bring in to
shore up my coherent theory and
introduce constraints on it a
sufficiently clever story Weaver can
find a way to weave those in and yet
still come up with a fundamentally wacky
view of things okay so that's kind of
the tacit problem of course you know
there are things we said in the favor of
the theory and some people still defend
it but most people I think don't accept
it and they don't accept it on both of
those grounds for the pragmatists theory
so the worry for the pragmatist theory
is roughly that the thing it just said
has almost nothing to be hood true yeah
and so you can formulate that in a
couple of ways firstly depending on how
sympathetic you are the ideas like this
if you did insist on the kind of
empiricism interpretation then it seems
to many people that there are candidates
for truth or falsity which don't look
like they're gonna have any experimental
predictions at all so classically is
there a god to me some properties of
that God whether you're an atheist or a
theist it seems like or even an agnostic
in some sense you're committed to there
being some troops wherever not we know
them and what they might be and it if
you interpret the pragmatist maximum in
a way which is of experimental
validation is what it means to worth
help me I just did air quotes you can
trust me if you watch me be very good
and so the experimental validation looks
like it's just gonna miss out on a bunch
of things which do seem a candidates for
truth and the other worry is is it just
looks like you can have kind of a useful
lies right so if I usefulness is
relative to a goal and you get different
goals it's part of the same things too
coherent
I is like there's this indeterminacy
right exactly that right so precisely
because you can imagine so now I have
another parameter to play with inside
swings true like what I believe how the
world is and what I'm trying to do and
now it looks like I can worryingly make
things trough fools by varying that
third parameter and that just seems
irrelevant there wasn't like what we
were initially trying to do everyone
truth to be Univ a London subway right
and this is some kind of sense and so
that puts a lot of people off the
pragmatists theory I mean also it was
unpopular for because in a way which
people who I think is fair after the war
Bertrand Russell sort of alleged it was
complicit with fascism in some kind of
way because he was like that one yes of
the the line being that like well if
anyone gets to pick the guy okay and so
you end up some kind of like what's
useful is what's useful to the vault and
then yeah they were in this all facts
world and so you know that was another
thing that I think that contributed to
its unpopularity and then the
correspondence theory which is probably
still of those three the most popular of
them and the most common sensical and
the most common sensical yeah it's more
or less viewed by a lot of prospers to
it has a kind of dilemma it faces where
I thought it seems a bit trivial it
doesn't really explain anything it's
like okay I want to know what truth is
you told me that truth is consists in
correspondence to reality well you've
just used a lot of other fence you were
in which sound kind of like describing
what reality was responding yes if you
just leave it at that or something not
much more sophisticated than that then
people worried it well it's not really
informative you haven't told me anything
about truth at all on the flip side you
feel sorry for the cross once they get
that complaint but then whenever they
fit in the details
philosophers start to worry that it's
kind of crazy metaphysics and if somehow
I hope you still like tell us nothing
I'd also tell us things are just
certainly force uh-huh which is you know
something which I thought only my
students could achieve
I've been accused of that many times and
so they're the worries you know if you
really start taking seriously I did okay
it's not just that there are cats and
Matt's and sometimes they sit on each
other but also in the world there is
this ordered complex which isn't quite
any of those things individually but
which is the the unity of them out there
in the world and there is this
relationship you can form between your
utterance and that thing apparently
instantaneously reaching out to this
ortant context and obtaining fading to
obtain and people just like what on
earth are you talking about like it
becomes people's worrying in this life
there's no way of spending that thing
out which won't end up invoking
mysterious entities logistical and so
for many people that was while some
people do still endorsed that I mean if
losses aren't that in verse two wacky
metaphysics but that is operating to
some people and so has suffice to put
many people off the correspondence their
truth okay
what are we left with well so watch me I
said you can we talk about those forever
but the author not like I'm not
necessarily giving it literally
accepting but clearly if people are
rejecting those three so wide since this
is kind of why initially was getting at
when I said it's distinct about for us
because this is I'd say the following
about to outline is the view most
distinctive to contemporary attitude
philosophy I never hear it anywhere else
and I think it's a large part of why
scientist and frost and of different so
much on truth so the last view nowadays
which i think is more popular and i
think it's the most popular it's more
popular is what's called deflation ism
according to deflation ism it's not a
great sales pitch it's it's really not
and i'm you know as i explained it to
you it's gonna sound really pouring but
you know it's your podcast you're
probably so the according to deflation
ism to say something is true is almost
just to repeat it it's it's the truth is
just a kind of a linguistic device which
helps us streamline certain
conversations but does nothing more than
that so there's this sort of classic
schema which is an x is true if and only
if
X so snow is why it is true just in case
snow is white snow and if snow is white
mr. white is true um so it sort of
leaning into the objection to the
correspondence theory that it's just
feels like saying yes it's trying to
make a virtue of that and it's saying
that having that schema the truth schema
available to us it allows us to do some
things which we might not otherwise be
able to do you have to clean it up a bit
technically if you just run out on that
schema you end up with a contradiction
consider the sentence this sentence is
false if I'm allowed to say this
sentence is false is true then I'm I'm
gonna be in trouble because this
sentence is false is true if and only if
this sentence is false and oh so you
have to clean it up a bit but if you
clean it up to avoid contradictions then
the thought is a theory like that
technically it allows for some
mathematical results you can speed up
proofs you can ensure that proofs can be
made short or if you're allowed to
invoke that kind of thing and
linguistically it allows to do what
people who blind descriptions where I
can do things like say whatever Shawn
said last night was true well I don't
need to know what you said I can kind of
affirm it in a convenient way so it it's
not the only linguistic way of doing
that task but it's one linguistic we're
doing a task says a bunch of kind of
thing tasks truth does for us in terms
of expressing agreement or doing some
mathematical work but it's nothing more
to truth than that there's no deep
metaphysics here there's no kind of
interesting theory of what this amounts
to it's kind of it's as if you having a
self I was just about to say an
interesting theory of pronouns but
actually that's super debated things
about which there were no right so truth
is that uniquely uninteresting uh-huh
and so that's a view which is very
popular in analytic philosophy which is
process has no option uptake anywhere
else the relevance of this I think is
very often when people outside of answer
philosophy but I think especially in the
sciences here talk about being true then
truth has I think in auditory language
often has a kind of um has connotations
which are sometimes moral like you know
being a truthful person is a good thing
to be and sometimes a bit mystical you
know the Christ says here's the truth
so that seemed sizzle imbue of a degree
of religious significance and also
unrelated to this in fact this would be
something which almost all of the
theories I just named to project but
also has often taken to be related to
certainty so if I say something like is
true I'm kind of like really backing it
up I'm affirming it in a strong way at
MIT and all of those things are totally
separate for philosophers rustlers
especially I mean not just but
especially if you have that deflation of
you it doesn't have any moral
significance it's just like means of
summarizing things you know it doesn't
have any connotations of certainty it's
unrelated to that and it doesn't have
any use of spiritual religious
significance but if I say something like
the universe is expanding how do i
categorize that within a deflationary
theory do I say I mean is it possible to
make sense in a statement that's true
well it's a on a deflationary theory you
know you have whatever you want to say
about the universe expanding presumably
as someone who's very educated in
physical theory like yourself when you
say that thing in the background there's
a kind of there's a theory of what it
means for University expanding there's a
sense of like what kind of things we
should expect to observe and as a whole
bunch of statements connected with that
when you say those things you know that
licenses me to now make predictions on
those grounds to ask to assume that
you're gonna affirm the consequences of
that claim and stuff like that but it
being true doesn't add anything to
saying like saying the universe is
expanding or saying it's true the
universe explained doesn't add anything
new to all of those helmets which what
is that it makes it it it makes it very
I don't say subjective but it's from the
point of view of people talking rather
than from the God's eye view like
scientists would like to say that you
know when they discovered the universe
is expanding rather they're contracting
that would have been just as true if
there were no people around talking
about it right can I still say that in a
deflationary well that's a bit
complicated in some sense yes right
because you can just say for instance
you can say the exact sentence you just
said even if no one had discussed it the
universe would still have been expanding
and that has
and I get rather complicated but perhaps
that makes certain predictions
I mean that maybe that's for instance
affirming that there aren't any sort of
causal dependencies between our words
and the rate of expansion or thing like
that and those are all things we can
test and we can be to bet amount we can
create them I disagree with them but
saying it's true sort of doesn't do the
work of affirming that thing to like
them to to get that out you need to sort
of make additional claims and make your
argument for those claims for instance
that there aren't these causal
dependencies so I think what a deflation
stood like to say is anything you were
inclined to say by means of using the
predicate truth you can still say under
their theory it just won't be the case
that like the property of being true is
ever doing any work I think I'm finally
getting I'm and so that's why it's
deflation Airy right they're not so to
speak deflating what claims you can make
about the world what they're deflating
is what the role truth plays - so it's
not a bit clean it's not a theory of
objective reality or you know it's not
denying realism it's just that this
truth relationship is nothing so special
yes that's right and so this view it's
sort of the common objections to this
view
firstly I made this of glib remarks Lina
up to go to the contradictions yes you
can correct yeah there are thenns of
multiple things you are left with and
you have to decide which of the ones you
prefer and that ends up being
controversial and the other thing people
object anything is the goes back to
Michael Dermott but that is a lot of
people makes patrician is that it just
misses out a key part of what truth does
which is that we want true beliefs the
point of inquiry is to like get true
beliefs rather than false beliefs and
the deflation is you know while they
have of course F things to say in
response objection they seem to be sort
of missing out a key role of my true fan
out conceptual mental lives if they
don't have that so dumb it rather
describes it describes it as if you
explain to someone the rules of chess
the nature of the pieces and whatnot and
then decline to mention that the point
of chess is to like check the opponent
yeah like you really haven't explained
what chess is and this you also give the
people with that detail and so the
worried about deflation is
is kind of its account of the role of
truth in our lives is communicative
roles these technical roles is missing
out a key thing and explaining that key
thing you have to invoke something a bit
more substantial Avella truth is to
explain why we care about getting in the
first place let me pause for a second to
talk about policy genius we all know
that something like life insurance is
the kind of thing we're responsible
grown-up people have it and know what
they're doing but we also know that it's
kind of a pain and kind of intimidating
I mean how much do you need what's the
best policy to get policy genius makes
that all a lot easier what they do is
they offer a marketplace which shows you
quotes from all the top life insurance
companies all at once so you can compare
what they have to offer it saves you a
lot of legwork you can save up to $1500
or more a year by using policy genius to
find the policy that's right for you
once you apply the policy genius team
handles all the paperwork all the red
tape all that stuff is free they're in
contact with life insurance companies
every day monitoring developments and
helping customers navigate every step so
if you're one of the many people looking
to buy life insurance right now but
you're not sure where to start
head to policy genius calm they'll find
you the best rate and handle the process
completely you can stop worrying about
life insurance get back to baking your
own bread adopting a furry friend or
just being a kind and considerate human
is part of the motivation for
considering theories like this there's
this benefit tarski established right
about he was thinking and guess he
followed girdle right girdle showed that
there were certain statements that I
would say you know are true in a formal
system but you can't prove them and
tarski basically proved that there were
statements that sounded like they should
be true but you couldn't prove them
unless you're exactly had to say it like
it's like the the statement P is true if
and only if P is true is not a theorem
something like that
so say listeners you can't see i'm also
noting i do air quotes notes when I'm on
so do I they're either used to it so I'm
gonna get more complaints that I don't
have video my
I guess now but okay yeah I just love
creating problems you know so I came so
broadly yes there is a relationship
between tasks ease work and go does work
and deflation ISM was kind of one of the
big props of support for it was that
people were able to sort of take tasks
ease work and say once you have tasks
ease work that's really all you need
from a theory of truth
so what tasky did more or less was find
a way the first the first rigorous and
consistent way of retaining a lot of
that you know Phi is true if known efi
formula without running into those
contradictions the way he did it was by
saying what you need is a kind of
hierarchy of languages where in the base
level there's no truth predicate at all
then a level above that you can speak
about formulas in a level below that and
include as being true and you can have
sort of another level of truth predicate
we could also affirm those ones and so
on and so on you just live with the
infinity of hierarchy yeah that's kind
of one way of trying to get a consistent
theory of this there are there are other
ways of doing this there are also people
who try and avoid the hierarchy so like
Thoreau there's now a lot this is a
thriving technical field of mathematical
logic which is looking at how to do this
yeah it's pretty firstly technical if
you look at these page yes write it
quickly gets really very dangerous and
it's all surprising theory of trying to
give some axiomatic theories where
you've axioms governing the truth
predicate and see how they behave so
there's kind of you know this there's a
thriving technical field which is
related but not as closely related as
you might think
so those for a sort of who theories I
just mentioned like toski for instance
in his work at various times suggested
he was doing something kind of like a
deflation area theory and also something
kind of like a correspondence theory and
it's not really clear that he knew the
correspondences
yeah he certainly didn't seem to know or
care that much was and I have just
guaranteed you a bunch of angry
it's gonna forward them to you don't
worry Don but so good now you convinced
me that I had little idea of what truth
is but also given the history a hundred
years from now no one's going to accept
any of these we haven't settled yet
anyway right yes it does look like
equilibrated yes it died well as far as
I can tell Osby only ever knocks things
out of equilibrium but I mean yes right
now I'd say if I was to make a
prediction about where this is gonna go
is there we'll eventually have to be
some kind of unification of the advanced
technical work with the more traditional
theories of what truth amounts to right
there has already there are some
magicians who are now in a sort of
building on task ease initial
suggestions to be serious it was a very
good scholar of this theater and um who
are trying to claim that in some sense
you can see this technical work as a
vindication of deflation ISM but like
all I need to do is lay down kind of
sparse or very minimal rules yeah so
you're starting to get that there are
other people going in our directions too
but I predict that as time goes by we'll
get more of a sense of how the technical
logical mathematical more scientific
work relates to the sort of traditional
high-level philosophical work and that
will give us a sort of better
understanding of what truth is and what
kind of role it plays for us okay good I
want to I want to sort of go back to
moving this to connect with science once
again but I think there's still some
more philosophy that we need to get out
of the way um you know when we talk
about true statements or we don't when
we talk about statements different kinds
of truth right there's things that you
can imagine proving logically things
that you have to go out and
experimentally verify right so and I
know that let me try to say this in my
words and then you can fix it there's
there's the notions of the reasons why
things are true some things are true in
virtue of themselves or the definitions
of their words and we call those
analytic there are things that are
virtually true
you know because that's how the world is
but it might have been otherwise and we
call those synthetic there's also how we
know that things are true there are
things we we know just from reason alone
a priori and things we know by going and
doing experiments a posteriori so these
are two very similar sounding things but
a little bit different do they get it
mostly right and that's yet reasonable
summary of the traditional distinctions
you're driving yeah yeah and so to me
and I guess to David Hume it sounds like
there's this very close connection
between a priori truths ones that are
true that you can sort of show just by
logic and analytic truths ones that are
true just by virtue of their definitions
whereas there's another relationship
between postgre synthetic things that
you you know go out and and well how did
i defined synthetic I forget but
synthetic sounds like a posteriori
analytic sounds like a priori yeah do
people basically buy that I know that
the money will can't try to argue there
was wiggle room there yes so Kant
famously argued that there's a category
of things which are so synthetic making
substantial claims not just about not
just given in their definitions but
really making claims in the world but
which are nonetheless a priori rights
are things you know by means of reason
reason alone and as far as I can tell
and this is another one where Discoverer
eventually I'm just gonna have to say
it's colors still of it like you can't
get me fired I'm safe now and so you
know subject to correction from scholars
can't seems to have been kind of
thinking about then relatively
relatively recent Newtonian science and
thinking like he was very confident like
finally we've achieved knowledge we know
something about nature which is that it
works on body using Newtonian lines and
it's sort of the dominant epistemology
from any sources primarily Locke on the
European continent was that this is kind
of experiential knowledge we know this
because we've done the right kind of
experiments getting the right kind of
experiences and it sort of validates our
claims I'm still just finding worked out
to do that and can't saw that that
couldn't
quite work and the reason it couldn't
quite work he thought and I think many
people agree with him is that some of
the claims and that seem to be necessary
for Newtonian physics didn't seem to
admit of those kind of tests for
instance it seems to people at the time
although we would now disappear this but
it seemed to at the time that that space
is has something like Euclidian
structure was it was something we
presupposed when we did our experiments
we didn't test that rather when we were
making other like testing claims about
the distance between things or the speed
at which things moved we would be were
then presupposing him and so Kant wider
this seemed therefore like this is war
in fact that like a bunch of really
foundational claims to this science
which he really want to validate as like
a achieving knowledge of the world were
just not supported by the means that we
had to support things and so can't bill
us or philosophical apparatus to explain
how there could be some claims actually
which were substantial for instance that
space is Euclidean structure while at
the same time not requiring empirical
validation we could know that just by
reflection and so that was the continent
was peopled the synthetic a priori okay
and that sounds wrong especially because
it's not even exactly true that space
has in Euclidean structure right so that
might have been a little premature on
the money was part yes and now right so
it's it's a little bit complicated what
the relationship is between what Kant
said and what eventually became refuted
I mean it did so much he's not a
famously clear right not quite enough
and the in particular the issue is it's
not like what happened was we stopped
having apparently a priori roles for
some kinds of geometric structure if
it's we may not use the particular one
which Kant thought we had to use but
still there's something playing a
similar some people might argue there's
something playing a somewhat similar
role I befrank have no real opinion
about this and those people are wrong
does he help yes but some people claim
that like
right a sufficiently high level of
abstraction you could maintain can't
scream he was just too specific in
saying this is particular structural
space has to have but he wasn't wrong
that's based us to have that we need to
a priori attribute to space some kind of
structure in order to do our reasoning
and but there he said this is where
we're getting back in the truth right I
mean there I'm open to the idea that
there are preconditions for us making
sense of the world but that's different
than saying those preconditions are true
right you can then say and I have made
some sense of the world therefore
empirically I've verified that this
particular presupposition works um well
I guess you know this does actually this
might be a point where which of those
theories of truth we endorse makes a
difference to how you want to understand
what's going on yeah right so more or
less um you know for the deflation is to
say that you know it's true that space
has such a structure is more or less
just to repeat its basis such a social
structure so once you've told me your
theory you're not adding anything to it
by telling me it's true and to that
extent kind of this does not really you
just disagree I mean I say he is in iron
the deflation Asst I would just disagree
with the claim that like to say the
space as a structure is different from
saying is true at its base as a
structure on the other side to
corresponds its theorists maybe there
might be more involved because maybe
when you say that it's space as this
structure there's something extra
involved in saying and that corresponds
to some external thing maybe some claims
are like different and they don't need
to have that correspond straight this
would be a vegetable people who true
pluralism where they have that um
there's kind of more to the
correspondence variation because
different claims correspond throughout
in different kinds of ways and so I need
to tell you not just that space as a
structure but what kind of
correspondence relationship you need to
be looking for in order to bear this
kind of claim out and that would make it
such that there is like a little bit of
extra work to be done at least in
explaining exactly what you mean when
you say space as this structure and so
this might be a point where like which
of those theories are true seems
tempting to you at least makes a
difference to what kind of things you
think you need to do to fully
explain what you mean okay make things
faster from space that's fair but it
does sound like at least provisionally
I'm okay in making my naive statements
about you know there are mathematical
and logical truths and there are
scientific truths and they're different
so no I just didn't get to that yet so
you have all the time don't worry alas
in the 20th century this kind of
Association of Klein eventually Kant's
dis division between analytic and
synthetic cures true solution foot which
are true in virtue of their meaning
versus truths which are true in virtue
of something about how the world is
independent of language came under quite
stone criticism of in philosophy and
more or less the criticism was that like
so to speak it's a little bit arbitrary
how you categorize things on one side of
this versus the other okay so the the
thought being that uh you know I'm not
quite sure what the voice because I've
always fought your tax was just City we
can categorize whole regions of
philosophical debate is so easy oh but I
mean I guess it's just the thought being
that on this notion of an analytic truth
something true in virtue of meaning when
you try and cash it out it's kind of
soon as little place for the
correspondence theory when you try and
cash it out what you'll find is it
depends on notions which are themselves
quite mysterious and we don't have a
theory of it that you know you have to
sort of invoke notions of synonymy or
necessary equivalents which themselves
aren't well theorized and once you try
and like really think like this will
really make sense of it eventually what
you're left with is something more like
well there are some claims which I'll do
more to defend than others in terms of
you really have to do make them do a lot
of work to make me give up on the claim
that all bachelors are unmarried men
like that something which really really
really requires a pretty drastic change
in my worldview but you could do it like
you
could it's just so to speak I haven't
yet found the circumstance where it
would be convenient for me to give up
that claim but you could do it other
claims are sort of like closer to being
revisable in light of my experiences and
so what a lot of thoses came to think
was this notion of an achiever synthetic
was a sort of bad way of making
theoretical sense of this the difference
between how entrenched believes offer us
and like really all there is is this
entrenchment and that's a sort of much
more that comes in degrees so quite is
trying to give us a spectrum rather than
just a to option yes more or less things
to be more or less central to our belief
structure and but are you advocating
this or mentioning that there are people
who advocate it because it does not
sound very convincing to me I think that
all bachelors are unmarried men I am
mentioning it rather than yes okay I
tend to think that you know it's one of
those things where it relies on a
crucial point incitement is that there
are these sort of somewhat mysterious
notions we just can't make sense of
Quine the person who most influential
artists attack was making it in the 50s
just before there are a lot of
developments where we developed tools
where I think we can't just make sense
of those notions and so I I think it was
a sort of sensible in light of the state
of theoretical development at the time
but I don't think it really bears out
and so it's of entered philosophical law
that this was refuted but I think it was
of that decision Lawrence reexamination
in light of these developments yeah I
had this vague feeling from a completely
unqualified perspective that if we fix
some things up in our use of language
and logic and things like that there
would be a clear distinction and maybe
it has to do with possible worlds and if
something is true is in every possible
world or something like that that's
different than being true in some
possible worlds but not others well
that's like some of the technical
machinery which philosophers used to
analyze bunch of concepts will be in
terms of what's called modal logic which
is the logic of possibility and
necessity oh how philosophers tend to
think about that is they will have
possible worlds which dependent I
describe them or have a kind of like
concrete real existent worlds just not
ones we can physically yeah that's one
scientists don't care about yeah they're
cause preserved by that yeah also more
more cecily just like sort of complete
descriptions of the world which you
could like which may or may not be
actual which may not endorse which may
not be true but you can sort of give
their subscriptions of the world acid
sorry I really need to before I forget
mentioned that Max tegmark previous
podcast guest really does believe in all
the other possible worlds also he's a
he's a Matthew version of David Thewlis
well you know one of the genuine and I
mean is of genuine joys of being in
academia is whenever I think something's
just do wacky and no one who believed me
who liked have a passionate defenses of
that yeah and you know I'm just left in
awe of what the human mind can do but
but yes right so you could view possible
possibilities it's just sort of stats
things descriptions of how the world
might be and then the solve the
apparatus of modal logic is a way of
reasoning about like or giving it you
know if we think of ourselves in these
in this space of possibility
possibilities what follows what's
necessary from here what's the only
possible from here etc and some of that
machinery can be bought in to try and
make sense of the notions required to
make sense of Anna olicity you know I I
don't want to give anyone the impression
that this is settled like I happen to
think you can do it but there you know
there are reasonable in terms of people
who don't think you can do it but like
those are exactly develops I have in
mind and that just kind of is a sort of
nice illustration really of you follow
this story right there's we begin of
kind of already in modern Europe appears
of a time interaction between like
philosophy and scientific perfection
where you have philosophers and
scientists trying to think about like
how can we be confident and what seems
like a very well grounded theory from
that we get use of technical
mathematical machinery designed to try
and like help us make sense with those
notions which Frost was then used to
solve problem as high as some of the
initial notions are theory they was
built on but then that itself spurs new
technical developments and we are like
getting best tripping also validators
and it's kind of it's a really nice sort
of virtuous circle of critique and
response to critique innovations to very
imposed new tools and allowing us to
make sense of things which are hard to
make sense of before good and I think
this leads us
right into the sort of scientific
practice that I was hoping to get to
right I mean sight that what the system
you just described is what science would
ideally like to be like with a little
bit of data thrown in right we come up
with theories we compare them with data
we still unfortunately teach kids at
least in the u.s. that there's something
called the scientific method that
Francis Bacon laid down and all
scientists follow and you know a little
baby hypothesis grows up to be a theory
and then finally graduates to being a
law none of that is actually true in
scientific practice but there is some
sort of you know the the give-and-take
between hypothesis hypothesizing and
collecting data is certainly there
I mean well what is your read on a
better way that we might teach high
school students how science is done then
the Baconian scientific method yeah
right that I'm Frank this is a really
fascinating topic and it's actually
something I think about professionally
where exactly as you say I mean it's the
same in the UK people are taught this
kind of stylized vision of scientific
method it really just doesn't correspond
to how I think science and practice
works and even how it should work
it wouldn't be good if we tried to make
science work like that and the irony is
very thick a theory that has no
relationship to experiment so I I think
you know right now I think the best bet
I could have for how to reform
scientific practice my celebrated
scientific education would be to base
actually on some ideas from a different
for us so this would be a Dewey from the
American practice sessions where Dewey
was this kind of famous educational
theorist is actually one case we had
most influenced and he has of
learn-by-doing was the philosophy and he
really actually kind of modeled his
whole theory of education on what he
took to be kind of a more realistic
model of scientific inquiry is done and
the idea would be you sort of give
people problems materials with which to
solve those problems and space to
reflect on what they're doing as they're
doing it and so you know you you give
people some materials and tell me
um how can I make this this chemical do
that
alright turn this con up whatever it
might be they then get some space to
like play around er the materials they
got and then afters they've got to tell
you what did you do and why in the
process of doing this you're gonna learn
a bunch of facts about scientific
inquiry because in some sense science is
that kind of activity but scaled up and
in much more communication other people
and so for instance a classic example
hissa which doesn't tend to feature much
in stylized descriptions of Santa a
method but it's actually super important
and is the subject of much debate now
around the replication crisis you know
at some point when you're testing a
claim you have to stop testing it stop
seeking new evidence and decided I have
enough evidence to write this up how do
you do that what the rules which decide
how you do that
that doesn't feature at all in the
normal picture of the sort of the
stylized picture of psychic method it's
sort of a sometimes people talk as if at
one point nature rings a bell as a
binary arrangement you got it or you
don't right exactly
if you set children that task they would
have to discover that problem because
you have to at some point work out like
now we've done enough because then this
is the way it's done and in so doing
they could reflect on like what kind of
features of this scenario made me think
that now with the time to do that when
what would have made me think we need to
do more with if it means to do this and
so by engaging in scientific research
they'll learn kind of key features of
how the practice is done how these
decisions can be made in a way which
like don't fit the Stars method book on
arbitrary I are responding to features
your investigate situation and we do so
I know which is kind of fun right yeah
and this is the kind of thing which I'd
be really interested in there being much
more experimentation around yeah but I
think the part that is valuable or
important to me that maybe you didn't
mention there is this idea that we are
comparing different possible worlds we
have hypotheses that's going back to the
previous discussion like a big part of
the scientific method is saying I don't
know which world we live in like there's
different theories that might describe
the world they're all theories that
describe some world which one do we live
in so we're gonna collect more data and
maybe it's not by
but at least as good Bayesian zwi will
increase our credence in one of these
hypotheses and decrease in the other
well I mean actually I would hope that
look a good process of doing education
would help people do that because like
one of the things one wishes to learn
right is what kind of experiments are
worth doing and eventually you need
learn that like some experiments don't
differentiate between hypotheses because
in either of these possible worlds you
would expect the same given this test
and so in learning about like or how do
I do an experiment which decides or this
gives me evidence relevant to deciding
between these hypotheses you're having
to think about in a better process of
doing that like you still have to hold
in your mind well what would be true of
this hypothesis and what would be true
of that hypothesis listeners should be
aware I've now been very helpful hand
gestures for each hypothesis so what
would be true in each of those
hypothesis so do the work out what the
consequence would be and how they'd
apply for the materials you have
available and you know that is a sort of
baby version of something like
hypothetical deductive reasoning which
is if not the be-all and end-all or
Sciences at least part of it and that is
also a type of reasoning which
necessitates you thinking about
different possibilities and so again
like allowing like throwing people into
scenarios long as they have the time to
communicate and reflect of each other
really I think actually teaches in
practice a lot of these things as long
as you sort of guide them to like point
out features of that here that you've
just done right and so yes like I
certainly agree that like a core feature
of any scientific reasoning is like in
some sense it's a contra intuitive but
it's actually important we reason about
what's not actual you know like science
requires that you reason about
possibilities which aren't true which
aren't accurate descriptions for the
world and that's kind of interesting in
many ways I also come out to think so
you first said like there's a core
reason why them you say like now I have
my model isn't that true like almost all
models in fact involve false claims
right right so that can't quite be right
and so they're all these times when in
science where kind of another thing
people would learn really by doing this
is in some sense science doesn't just
consist in like saying true things
there's a bunch of like non true stuff
you have to deal with but that doesn't
invalidate it either and one of the
advantage balla dates is that
how in fact we gain reliable knowledge
and so one of the advantages which
philosophers like a Heather Douglas or
Phillip pitcher often claim for citizens
or young people being able to do this
kind of more engaged duty in education
is that a lot of attempts to undermine
public trust in science involve pointing
to these features which people aren't
aware a typical feature of scientific
practice but which is just part of how
we do things and then point out like you
know well did you know that these models
involve a bunch of false assumptions so
how can you really trust what the
climate scientist is saying if you knew
how science works like yeah the models
involve those assumptions it's not how
we do modeling right like and so you
know by giving people practice and
seeing for themselves like oh you know I
like I made some simplifying assumptions
that wasn't a problem that's what
allowed me to get the answer it would in
immunize them in some sense to certain
kinds of spurious skeptical attacks
right right Andy but the idea I really
just maybe I was repeating myself but
the idea that we could be wrong you know
that that we are not simply purely
reasoning our way to how the world works
is very crucial to me in science I
remember hearing a talk by an unnamed
evolutionary psychologist who was
founding an institute or something like
that and you know they made it very
clear the purpose of our Institute is to
show that blah blah blah is true and I
wonder raise my hand it's like that's
not really great science II there how
about to find out whether or not it is
true this is slightly there's a slight
but important distinction
Wolfe's I mean I'm an employee of the
London School of Economics this
department was founded by Karl Popper so
I'm legally obliged to agree with what
you just said but there are some
philosophers heretics who might think is
at least a bit more complicated now I
mean you know chuckles I die honestly
I'm actually pretty sympathetic to a
broadly focused vacation it's what we're
up to in science it doesn't always sit
so easy if the businessman said I say
for now but um well sorry I'm much more
Bayesian I'm not very falsifiable like I
think I got in trouble by writing a
paper saying beyond the title is beyond
falsifiability right and to point out
that look this was
hopper put his finger on some things
that were really really important but
it's not the final solution of the
demarcation problem and i'm i think that
bayesian ism helps get us closer to a
more nuanced view right okay i mean in
that case i think we pretty pretty
sympathetic like i think there's
something to be said for the
falsifications picture but i agree it's
not the big one end either either way
you have this idea that you could be
wrong yes but was gonna mention is you
know there's a vision of scientific
practice which is in some sense
dependent from kuhn although I'm quite
sure Koon would probably not want to be
associated with some of the people you
perhaps have in mind um we're in like
the way science works right is by saying
our paradigms those paradigms involve
kind of not unquestionable least
relatively unquestioned assumptions and
it's all legitimate to go forward like
the way I do science is like in light of
those assumptions I'm now going to draw
out the implications in testable for for
other things you can make sense of in
light of those but not necessarily
Tesla's I mean we're in the lacquer Tosh
building right now and soul a collage is
famous for saying you know scientific
theories have a protected or hard core
in the sensor and that you know it's
eventually that can be penetrated but
it's a reasonable procedure to begin
with assumptions but you that's willing
to give up in some sense that actually
relates to the client in point you're
saying earlier but many who do think a
sort of reasonable vision of how
rational inquiry goes is you have some
briefs which are much more central which
are much less willing to give up and
it's okay to do things by first trying
to swap out the the less well the less
core believes in seeing how you can do
things and of course you can imagine a
sort of quasi Bayesian justification
well this is why you know one of the
issues with falsifiability as a solution
the demarcation problem is there's
plenty of examples where I have a theory
it's very well-established an
experimental result comes along that is
in contradiction to that theory and
everyone in the right mind says oh don't
worry that result will go away hey I
still think like Ghostbusters yeah would
be an example yes that's right yeah I
mean scientists you know do they have
their
pre-conditions they have their what we
call cherish principles this is what we
like to call them right and you don't
want to give them up but eventually you
end up doing it if you get enough
evidence against it and to me that kind
of fits in with the correspondence
theory a little bit all right with the
coherence theory yet I wanted to sell
you a little bit you same about how to
be coherent is to be coherent amongst a
bunch of beliefs and like some of them
will be more switch out a bowl than
others right right so since then will be
more foundational some of your beliefs
so the thing about both the pragmatist
and the coherence theories of truth is
they clearly pick up on aspects of our
mental lives which are important like we
do in fact have goals and beliefs do
help us fulfill those goals and there's
some reason to prefer a belief if it
helps you feel you go our beliefs can be
more or less coherent at least in the
sense of being self consistent not being
self consistent and you may prefer to be
self consistent I think there are true
contradictions yeah what may prefer to
be a self consistent and in that case
you know and so for that reason the
coherence theory must be picking up on
something because it's more or less just
saying that particular virtue of your
belief system being coherent like that's
the one which makes a difference for
truth
so what non-coherent theorists are gonna
say that we have a way of recovering
within our theory the importance of
coherence so for instance the
correspondence theorist will tend to
have a metaphysical theory about what
the facts are and just say like it turns
out that the facts can't be such they're
inconsistent of each other and so if
your theory is incoherent in a sense of
being inconsistent we know it's false
because we know that the facts aren't in
clear that's fair everyone wants to be
coherent does whether or not that's the
same quinone yeah and so right and and
and so what you'll find is that theories
of truth and it is I think one of the
reasons why on theory of truth tends to
like so much time attracts people to
deflation ISM is it tends to be the case
that you can like recover whatever nice
things you want to say about once
they're true within the other theory of
truth and you know without just being
addressed vacation for the fish nism it
kind of prompts
thought that like truth it doesn't
really matter what you end up saying
about true if you always find a way of
saying the nice things you want to be
able to say anyway I said like truth
isn't really doing much there you just
have some additional principles you're
able to bring in which get you the the
goods you want this is sort of a dirty
little secret of philosophy that so much
of it is driven by things you want to be
the case and then finding ways good
things you want to be the case either
case or maybe that's a virtue I don't
even know but certainly when I think of
moral philosophy at all well I mean
clients it may be even epistemology I'm
not sure I'm a dirty little or a secret
[Laughter]
dirty it's certainly the case that um so
does good so is it a secret I mean
people say mean things to be on the
internet all the time we've suggested I
think this is gross fee so penny penny
of people apparently knows about
philosophy is it little or dirty and is
it more complicated because yes it's
true that philosophy as a field
precisely because it's kind of
relatively unconstrained by direct
empirical data or rather the
unconstrained by self rigors of proof
mean that you know if you come in was
like I'm really committed to keeping
this principle you can find a way of
constructing the worldview which retains
that principle but which has other
desirable features and some philosophers
more or less to stick and that's the
game right let's lower the game is you
come in of the things you're really
committed to my commitment like and you
have that and the world will no doubt
still present you with puzzles right so
you know I just mentioned I believe
they're true contradictions suppose you
don't like what do you want to say about
sentences like this very sentence is
false do you but so you do believe there
are two contradiction yes so I more or
less think what we want to say about
this very sentence is false is that it's
both true and false and so like if you
don't in and you know I don't not gonna
defend it right now but if you don't
think that like you have to do you have
to tell me something because it turns
out they're sort of pretty minimal and
apparently plausible things you might
say about true if I which will get you
that sentence is both true and false
and so you know it's not the alternative
must be that it's meaningless or
unsalable bouncing so you can have out
you can out bounce some house you can
have it's of like not well formed
because it you're applying a true
predicate to it so in a real kind of way
or you can have it such that it gets no
value like it just fails to be evaluated
but in any case like building of well
view which gets you either out of bounds
or meaningless or no well-formed or
whatever that requires work and so the
voice it's not a trivial game even if
you do come in if your strong
commitments like to build a theory which
does that and in the process of goading
those theories you often are forced to
do things which are themselves
intellectually quite valuable and so
some people will say that this activity
of kind of elaborating upon and
defending one's call commitments is
actually in the end intellectually very
valuable because if you take that game
seriously um you'll find it's really
difficult and what you have to do to
play it well is just a real driver of
innovation okay I put my best friends
are philosophers I don't want it no like
I just you know I I'm perfectly happy
with being so flow things so there you
go that works yeah but uh the the
speaking of self-loathing let's not let
scientists off the hook you already
mentioned the replication crisis I want
to get a little bit down-and-dirty into
the difference between the pristine way
which scientists and ie we think of
their own past time and the the ugly
truth of how it gets done and because
the ugly truth always becomes a little
bit prettier when you really like space
up to it right so what you're being
self-loathing you can take self-loathing
at all like someone's gotta love me why
not me is why is my attitude it's
certainly not the YouTube commenters I
know that I love you show so the
replication crisis you know you I think
most people have heard of it but why do
we say what it is sure so in social
psychology especially but not just in
social psychology it's in relatively
recent years been found that a bunch of
results which people took to be secure
which we're featuring
textbooks in which public interventions
were being based on in fact don't
replicate which is to say when we try
and retest the experiments which
initially validated that those phenomena
were real we find either that we can't
get the effect at all or it's much
reduced in its stranded for degree of
influence them initially thought so the
the sensing that's just replication
failure what made it a crisis were in a
sort of ill-defined sense this happens
so many times to so many results that
people felt that there was a sort of
systemic problem here I you know I
raised that explicitly because I'm often
a little bit underwhelmed by the
arguments to that second part like what
is the rate at which we should expect
true ideas in science like III I think
people are is blase about humans crisis
but nonetheless in the course of the
fact that this prompted a kind of panic
reactions to strong but this prompted
quite a strong reaction from the
scientific community in the social
sciences and statistics especially and
nowadays is well actually for a few
science led to a bunch of problems being
uncovered with the way science was done
or these things which people were pretty
clear could be improved upon and so now
there's a sort of a quite broad reform
movement sweeping through to Social
Sciences which is trying to address the
problems less identified and presumably
part of it part of the worry that it was
really serious was that like you say
it's not just random but reflects
systemic biases in the field when you
get an exciting result yeah that's where
you publish it right well you just get a
null result no one yes I mean one of the
fascinating things about was the
replication crisis is that a lot of the
things with of now responding to it in
life but all of these problems people
were aware of them in some sense for a
long time and so there's the kind of the
classic one is the file drawer problem
right where if I get a positive result
suggesting there is an effect that's
exciting especially with a new thing I
can go and publish that in a high
prestige journal which lots of people
will read and I'm aware of if I fail to
find anything and even if I just
replicate that um that's not exciting
it's much hard to get published and
often that information will only be
available to the
a scientist who did the photos movement
and so like there's a massive bias in
what kind of information is transmitted
to community at large now that has
certainly been a thing which people have
discussed a lot in light of their
application crisis but there's no way
that people only became aware of this
possibility inside and publishing in
2015 right like you know that that's a
thing we worry about for a long time
and so I think one of the things the
replication crisis is really done it's
like the replication failures with
dramatic and drew people's attention to
problems but what we're actually now
doing in light of that is really
cleaning up house in ways we probably
should have done a long time ago and so
right now of course there's a lot of
love and with some people sort of argue
with each other about what should be
done some people think defensives if you
like their life's work is under attack
but in the long run I'm actually very
optimistic that what this is is like
only doing what we should have been
doing for a long time and hopefully will
lead to a much stronger much improved
scientific process in the future but
once you do admit that even scientists
have biases then maybe they have other
biases as well right I mean this becomes
a problem of much wider scope and we can
start questioning I mean it people take
it seriously right it sounds like you're
questioning their integrity although
you're really not you're just you know
doing epistemology in some sense yeah I
mean so there are all sorts of other
biases besides gests of the bias towards
publishable or fancy more exciting
results enough ones which of course get
much attention is sort of like
demographic like gender biases for
instance and who can get published and
where we don't have those in physics but
I've heard the gender utopia which is so
but you know sunny that's like one
source of you know bias which just you
know really negatively affect a lot of
people's lives being serious and so
other kind of biases you might see are
for instance towards not just things
which the scientific community will find
exciting like in terms of publishing
fancy journals but also and this is kind
of very worrying in light of what we do
with science there might be biases
towards like the kind of thing which the
media will pick up on knowledge policy
people
pick up on and so that you get some
cases of what looks like outright fraud
and the outright fraud being driven
basically by the sense that there's a
way to sort of clout with the media and
with policymakers
and so like yeah all of these things do
influence how scientists behave they can
have the social biases which are very
common they they need to get published
in order to advance that career in fact
most of my research is about the effects
those career incentives have on working
scientists and also you know like anyone
else they want to change the world in
ways they view to be desirable and so
that desire to influence policymakers or
people who are going to make a
difference but that can really affect
their behavior and like yes like some of
these seem like they admit of relatively
relatively simple force look better
through the simple fix it's like it's
not exactly clear how to shape check the
photo problem but they're above
technical statistical actually Bayesian
methods would you statistically it's
better and you can also reform how
journals publish or like what kind of
things that give an uptake in such a way
that we can mitigate at least the
effects of the thought or problem but do
you have a solution for gender bias like
and you have a solution for the subtle
influences of wanting to be influential
in the world like you know like these
things so there are a bunch of things
here which are going to be like much
harder to to really fully correct for
but which are seemed which is were part
of the the phenomena we know is the
replication crisis um I think that what
we have to do kind of sub speakers do
our best to fix these things but also in
some sense it's just quite right for
people to decrease their trust in this
institution insofar as their trust was
previously based on a image of
scientific researchers or science as a
social process which made it immune from
those things it's not immune to those
things and so a well calibrated agent
trusts it to the degree that they're
taken into account the real presence of
these but sadly there are no well
calibrated agents right people either
think it's infallible or completely
untrustworthy alright that's the problem
I mean I'm not so pessimistic about that
but the reason I'm not so pessimistic is
just because I think I encounter people
quite frequently who are you know of
course not perfectly well calibrated but
much better calibrated than just
like unthinking deferens yeah versus
total skepticism to climate scientists
ruling on air to style reasoning and
those people who are familiar with it as
a practice I find that both philosophers
of science and also from scientists
don't tend to have this kind of attitude
except about their own work right and
then let's just saw you self-loathing or
widely overconfident and those nearing
two options um but so then relating them
to that previous book on education is
kind of woman by immunizing people I do
think that like it seems that
familiarity of the practice being
engaged with science tends to actually
give you a sense of like there really is
something unusually reliable about this
as a way of reasoning it's not it's not
just like any awful way of reasoning
about the world it really is something
special about it but the same time it's
not magic rival no and you know it's
only as good as you know lots of smart
people repeatedly failing but maybe
feeling a bit better could be um
and that's about right and so I I hope
that actually by sort of instances
democratizing science by bringing more
people in by giving more people an
experience of the practice of science
research much more calibrated house
actually done rather than the sort of
quasi authoritarian fish in rushes like
there are some laws we've discovered and
you ought to believe these laws and the
test consists of you repeating these
laws to me rather than that way of doing
if more proof incentive like what this
enterprise actually involves that would
actually really help that would create
those calibrated assistance so I think
there are some people who have it now
and I kind of I'm optimistically there's
a reasonably exportable method of
craymore people who are calibrated in
that kind of way it is I would like to
be optimistic also but before I become
optimistic I do an emphasize there's
even more ways to be pessimistic I think
that you know when it comes to biases
like gender biases and racial biases
that exist in science just as much as in
society
sure but then there's these softer
biases which probably also exist in
society where you know people who have
idiosyncratic ideas will find that they
just don't get paid attention to or they
don't get jobs or they don't get grants
and it's not like anyone is banning them
but they're just choose
not to pay attention to them and their
ideas can wither on the vine or not get
paid attention to for that reason and of
course they will say it's because the
system is biased against them maybe
they're right or maybe their idea this
isn't very good right and do we have any
objective way of telling these things no
I mean I think that one of the things
about calibrated agent group regard to
their trust in science just has to kind
of learn is that you know this is a
thing which I do think which Papa even
if he wouldn't put it exactly as I would
put it was he really have like the
fundamentals of this idea because what
science is so to speak a quasi
evolutionary process there are lots of
people throwing up lots of ideas lots of
the time most of the I do those ideas
don't survive a lot of them for good
reason occasionally we'll miss one which
we should have which we should have paid
more attention to but succeed we haven't
got anything better than just having
lots of people try their best and throw
themselves at a problem come up with the
ideas they come up with and as long as
there are incentives to pay some
attention to new ideas which they
usually are in science and talk about
that in a second like we can reasonably
hope that eventually we will catch we
will catch good valuable new ideas and
we will actually have something we will
eventually be able to build in them and
I think those incentives to take new
ideas ersity do exist in science because
if a new idea really does work out then
I can use it to bolster my ideas yeah
the thought being that if I have access
to some new experimental technique which
actually works some new mathematical
theory which allows me to make
inferences I couldn't otherwise have
made or whatever then suddenly I can do
a thing to bolster support of my days I
just have some incentive to be trying to
searching the field and looking out for
things which other people of mists which
might have found which might give me an
advantage in the kind of the race to get
my ideas taken seriously and so the
incentive structure of science does
provide at least some like push towards
taking news I did those ideas seriously
I you know I'm not pollyannaish like I
see a lot of my work is about how I
think we can do this better but these
are features of the present system and
it is easily built upon and strengthened
roughly we're not starting from nothing
here you did propose the radical
sounding idea of getting rid
pre-publication peer review is that
right yes I did
it's fine you know I I am someone who
spends too much of my life on Twitter
and I'm always getting into you know
political arguments about the hot-button
issues of the day on twitter.com and yet
nothing I have said has drawn me as much
controversy as the thing we should get
rid of pre-publication peer review this
is Inco offered work with my friend and
colleague Franco Harrison and the pair
of us have this paper which was kind of
in some ways a summary of the last few
years both of our research resolved we
realized that we were both coming to the
similar conclusions we put by has
different co-author this piece and what
we argue in there is that most of the
things which pre-publication peer review
is meant to do for us there's either no
evidence that it does it or some
evidence that it fails to do it and so
just be clear the words pre-publication
are important here so tell the audience
but you know you're defining the thing
that you want to get rid of so you know
right now how do many fields not in all
fields actually it's already changing in
some fields but in many fields the way
new ideas get taken up is sort of not
privately but in relatively small groups
a scientist or group of scientists
produce a manuscript they maybe share it
with some of their friends get feedback
and eventually they will submit it to a
journal the journal will have an
editorial boards and some editors they
say and reviewers and adjourned the
editor will send to reviewers the
reviews will decide whoever or not they
think it's good paper in my other
reviews advice the editor will publish
them on publish so up to that point the
people the the people who saw flick
decided whether or not this idea is
worthy of more attention from the
scientific community are whatever the
scientists immediate peer group the
editor and whatever the reviewers think
this then decides what claims are put
out there to try and garner more
attention on them our point about this
process is very labor-intensive it takes
a lot of time for a lot of scientists
it's actually also this is not really
relevant to our point but it's a very
extortion of businesslike
the scientific publication houses like
the most profit-making entities yeah
because they just get a bunch of free
labor from PhDs
yes and a small group of people of
putting a lot of effort to decide
whether or not an idea as we're sharing
it then gets out there and gets whatever
up take it take it gets once it's in a
journal more or less our question is all
of that labor in deciding whether or not
something is worth putting out to the
broader community and having them assess
it what does that achieve is there
anything is there any firm evidence that
that's doing something good for us
rather than just directly having putting
out on some kind of like archive which
is actually increasing the case in
physics and Prejudice our things done
sheilo economics is kind of moving this
way some fields are going this way but
just putting up on some kind of publicly
accessible space and having going
directly to the stage where the
community are able to assess it as a
whole philosophers often have this idea
of a working paper where like there's a
draft that four years right will be on
their website and people comment on it
before they submit it which are yeah
like in some sense kind of we want to
make it more like yeah um I often think
will be better because more like how I
think yes sir so yes what people claim
in defense of care of you are a number
of things and so the paper really
consists in us going through the various
rationales that I've been offered for it
and trying to assess the empirical
evidence for it now the papers code is
pre-publication pair of you a good idea
question mark and that's party to
reflect the fact that right now we think
the evidence isn't always as strong as
we'd like it to be before making a clear
assessment so we are trying we aren't
clear that to some extent what we want
to do here is just prompt people like
the tradition has given us this
expensive very large bureaucracy we all
spend all of our time on like don't just
inherit it and pass it on like do we
want to have and what's it doing for us
and you're not even necessarily
questioning peer-review but the idea of
not letting anyone read the paper until
it has been exactly right like we're
questioning pre-publication matter if
you you know in some sense we said it's
in the paper in
there's a sense which we want more pain
more people to be able to access and
evaluate the paper and for the the
opinions of the scientific community
about the merits of a paper to affect
the judgments of more scientists right
so that's in some way what we want so we
kind of link it to the open science
movement there's a sense of everyone
like open open mayor of you
if I open here if you know how is a word
for a different kind of thing but
related to a person um whereas you know
the claims differences peer review helps
us sort the good ideas from the bad
ideas or sue sort false claims from true
claims or like there's really not much
evidence you have a pair of you is is
achieving that and in some sense it's
because you know science is hard right
and two people a believes that hard
science Sean Carroll is actually winking
at me now he told me he's not fighting
but he means it he just thinks you are
incompetent but um like irony irony is
everywhere here's you never know serious
or not like in some sense the judgments
of a couple of people who just happen to
have got at first this they're not
necessarily gonna be great at deciding
whether all this really is an idea which
was what we all have examples of bad
papers that have gotten through here are
you and good papers that have been
stopped yeah and it's a kind of this a
you know you don't want to lean too much
on this kind of fasci but one time
experiment but illustrative there's this
kind of famous experiment where people
like like anonymized ends of lightly
changed non-essential identifying
details of classic papers that
incredibly high cited truth we submit
them for review and i think was like
half were rejected on grounds of serious
technical flaws um well in fact there's
another study I think that most highly
cited papers were rejected in one part
in the real world because the super
highly cited papers are gonna be a bit
more daring right a bit more it's way
easier as a practicing physicist I can I
can promise and and I should say
parenthetically I love refereeing in
peer review like it's I appreciate the
effort the
making papers better both from referees
and from editors I did not and I want
future editors assessing my work to know
I don't value what you do having said
that if you write a paper that is boring
but true it's way easier to get it
published if you write a paper that's
interesting and dare right now and that
is one of the things we address in the
paper there's a real reason to think
that um there's a kind of small C
conservative bias in peer review
precisely because and this is so to
speak inevitable like whenever we assess
a new idea we're assessing in light of
what we already know we already believe
that's inevitable but the problem is is
you're preventing other people from
being able to engage in that practice
unless a relatively small number of
people say it meets their standards and
you know I I think that on net this is
just a disadvantageous procedure as I
said like we are clear and I wish to be
clear in this podcast that like when I'm
not being cheeky my real opinion is like
there are plenty of times in the paper
where we say like what needs to happen
here is rather than assessing things
according to people's intuition about
what this is doing there needs to be
like proper sociological work on what's
actually happening yeah and very often
we don't do that like they just have a
sense that you know well surely this is
the sort of thing that a pair of you
must it must be selecting for quality
works great otherwise why would we do it
and you know no look at the evidences
yeah look at the evidence like it's just
like the the teaching of the scientific
method I mean there is this this idea
that we can just think our way into the
truth but sometimes you have to look at
whether it worked right now exactly and
pair of you is something which I think
was intuitive to many people that it you
know it surely surely can't huh and yet
and yet it does filter out a lot of
truly bad stuff right that if the edge
cases that are that we could yeah I mean
even that is kind of complicated right
because what's the importance of
filtering out pretty bad stuff because
people put truly bad stuff on the
Internet yeah anyway I've heard yes okay
so I hear if I got the wrong bit or the
opinion the wrong bit of the Internet
there are people with false opinions
just yeah there's a couple or do they
but in the meantime
uh-hum sister in the meantime you know
the only different the reason it's kind
of important such as scare quotes to
filter things out is the sense that
being put in a journal kind of is in
some sense of stamp of approval it's a
validation of that opinion in a world
without journals what does it matter
that one more person puts up a wacky not
very well validated opinion on the
Internet
what we say the one thing will be this
is one of the points will be
acknowledged most problems for our work
is you know we don't we think if you
really think about the word hard
journalist this is that thinking through
the hypothesis the possibility of kind
of thing if you think about that world
on precisely because there's no apparent
authority figure saying this is what
I've taken seriously a lot of the things
which peer reviews meant to do like it
doesn't we don't lose anything by not
having it that said there is something
valuable about having a means by which
like non scientists who might be
interested in science to know where to
look for the decent ideas now again that
pair of usually the scientists in a
different field yes yes oh yeah exactly
or people who does not experimental
matter now of course that pair of you is
a good way of doing that kind of depends
on you thinking it's selecting some good
ideas which we've previously argued
against but even if pair of you isn't
doing that it's probably a good idea for
something to be desired yeah and so to
speak it right now peer review is de
facto how we're doing it may be a good
thing to invest time and mental effort
into doing be think about how to do that
in a better way okay so that's one
example the bomb throwing you need to
wrap things up we should talk about
standpoint epistemology I was per day
one example of the bomb frame what's the
other oh you know I think that look I
think the the case that has been made
indubitably over the course at this
podcast is gaining true knowledge of the
world whatever that means is hard it is
sticky and it's not quite as algorithmic
as our high school education as might
have led us to believe and once you
admit that it opens up you know a whole
bunch of things like who decides and how
do we decide where the truth is once we
found it I mean
is this kind of consideration
amigo tell us what standpoint
epistemology is but how serious is the
connection between this sort of social
science E or even philosophical sounding
idea and the real practice of science
this is a big one um so standpoint
epistemology is a sort of idea which
comes out of actually comes out of
masses theory bits of gets more famously
taken up in feminists there in the late
twentieth century and which nowadays in
the early 21st century for future
business is I heard optimist at heart
climate change 2030 listeners thank you
I just think you know climate change
isn't gonna get us quick enough for that
to be irrelevant to people so which
nowadays is kind of like become sort of
a heated topic of dispute outside of
just academic circles rib again the
broad ideas stated very generally very
loosely of standpoint epistemology is
something like who you are what social
position you occupy makes a difference
to who like what you can know and how
reliable you're gonna be certain kinds
of reasoning tasks really what you can
know or how you know it or both
depending on formulation can be I for a
both okay um because how what what you
can know that's a really well fine if I
was gonna say that what you can know is
the easier oh no I have I I you know
insofar as I've waded into this debate
at all it's from a no blog post where I
argued if if you look at kind of some of
the precise formulations or the more
detail formulations of standpoint
epistemology which exists and kind of
internet philosophy excited PDS or
places where people are trying to define
it clearly for public audience then it
looks more or less just like the it
looks to be so long as you believe that
what kind of experiences you've had in
your life make a difference to what kind
of things will be a reliable informant
about then some kind of static point
epistemology is going to be true right
so if you assume that in a very second
gated town but where the sames of 1950s
America the the black people are gonna
be the janitorial and the maid staff the
white people then the black people are
gonna know both about the black color
and the white quarter but the white
people aren't gonna go into the black
bit of town and so if you're asking
people about this town it's lay out
where things are and you can sort of
you've got limited time and resources
cause town the black people they're more
likely to know especially sort of the
dead working-class people they're more
likely to know about the time and now
this the struck from there out of this
town just cuz they experienced more of
it and that's the kind of you know
that's a very basic example I'm not
saying that that would be the most
efficient way of finding out its town
but there is some reason to think that
if you are picking an informant in that
kind of way a thing a reasonable coral
up for you to look out for is the
demographics of who they are what kind
of social position you know I mean it's
kind of in arguable that there are
correlations between once identity
markers in one's knowledge right exactly
and so in some forms like standpoint
epistemology can more or less just be
trying to think through the implications
of that fact and so okay in that case
that might make a difference if you're
doing certain kinds of ethnography or
certain kinds of anthropology of
sociology of this town and so already
well the kind of a high level it's sort
of obvious point like in practice it
might make a difference to how you
carrot your research designer who you
want to ask things and so even that
apparently trivial point can have
implications and multiple implications
which is sometimes forgot there are
classic examples I'm not remember quite
right but I'm gonna get you the broad
structure of for early 20th century
anthropology where you'll find the
anthropologist was like literally only
like interviewing the men in town
because they had some sense it wasn't
just their own biases they did have some
sense that like the man or the important
ones who knows what's up
so party based on their biases ball so
party based on what informants were
telling them about the town except they
were tight here the male informants they
were hearing but there were times in
some of the rituals they were interested
in when the men and women would go into
different places and then of course if
you only interview the men you literally
just can't find out about some of what's
going on here and so it sounds trivial
but there have been times when people
even
simple correlational point has been
forgot and it has been fuller in ways
which attract people tending to trust
more those at the top of social
hierarchies and that just doesn't it
does always work and so I think even
it's very simple form standpoint
epistemology can be contentful and
important
I actually think another more
controversial but I would defend it as
the same instance is actually to me to
movement a lot of the like the slogan
belief women I think there's a very
reasonable explanation of in but there
are also three some information is it
but one reasonable thing it's picking up
on is like if you will go into a
workplace and you want to know who's
gonna like reliably say who's a sexual
predator who's dangerous here then you
have to think of who has the authority
to get away of things and what's the
distribution of Petra versus other signs
of sexuality and it's gonna be like just
many heterosexual men have power and
offices and so it's many to be women who
the mid wanted the relevant knowledge
and so there's some strong reason to
like believe them to trust them they're
the ones who know and so again that
seems to me to fall out that's a very
content full point but it fools out of
the quite basic thing now let me say
that's the like you know that's the
point where I think Sam pointed first
emoji is non-trivial has implications
for scientific and social life and which
we could afford to take more seriously
there are other versions of standpoint
of histology which apparently do want to
be saying a stronger thing and so often
the slogan would be a standpoint in as
an achievement and it is again goes back
to the original Marxist formulation but
has some of the other more modern
formulations also have his future we're
in the idea it like the idea of sort of
your social position gives you access to
certain kinds of knowledge isn't just
meant to be sort an empirical fact that
what these kinds of people tend to have
these kind of experiences they have so a
higher rate than chance its manic that
but rather there's something which is a
more substantial thing which is like the
proletariat standpoint which is seeing
things from the perspective of like a
worldview properly attuned to those
people's interests or something like
that and seeing things from that
worldview will tend to be producing more
accurate or more informed worldview I
think with that one spelling out the
content of that standpoint in that sense
the achievement the
the property protest area or women's or
whatever standpoint I think that becomes
philosophically much more difficult
because like you know you could just
imagine right like what is the true
woman's standpoint like it becomes a
little normative also in a different way
than simply epistemological you I mean
it's it's meant to be in some sense you
know epistemology just tends to be
normative right like we're trying to say
when we say what knowledge is usually
knowledge is taken to be a good thing
and so if I tell you what knowledge is
I'm some sustaining succeed by way of a
leaf and this is Ione it's kind of try
and do that as well like I'm just people
who sort of have this drama version will
say like the proletariat standpoint or
the standpoint of oppressed women or
something like that that standpoint is
more successful at knowledge gathering
and reduce so this is an empirical claim
that could be tested well I mean did and
I mean I'm not good spokesperson for you
cuz I don't believe yet but I know like
um they might not want to agree that
because it depends what mean by
empirically tested because if these
templates can come apart what kind of
things are going to count as methods of
validating knowledge then it might look
you might worry that any test you do is
gonna you know people do to that just be
relative to the thing that life would be
circular or biased against it okay and
so well then it becomes less interesting
to me I mean I'm right it's just true by
construction or you're reputable I guess
so um but but just to just to make it
super duper clear none of this is going
to claim that whether you're black or
white or male or female or cysts or
trans affects whether the universe is
expanding Oh
whether you know the universe is
expanding right how not like who your
identity is affects the truth about the
world that's just not know right so I
guess you know some brave soul might
wish to argue as much but typically the
kind of claims people are concerned if
it's or things I had so it's gonna be
about like power relations in the work
place blank expiry human spirits we're
safe to go in this town if it's a
sundown town you know that kind of stuff
and so usually if you look how this
the thing for all of the kind of
cultural controversy around it often not
always but often if you look at the kind
of claim standpoint piss motorists are
interested in it's usually sort of
independently plausible that like the
sort of people they're saying have an
advantage and advantage of some sort in
knowledge gathering would have an
advantage about not discovering in that
case that you know I I know means wish
to say that's it all cases on
controversial in many cases there are
going to controversies but there's a
kind of core set of examples which
people will tend to find plausible and
then it's just how far can you expand
that rather than whether or not there
are any people don't usually expand it
all the way to like the fundamental
approaches of the physical because
muscles make that you well I think that
I bring that up intentionally because I
guess my first exposure to ideas in this
universe was as an undergraduate taking
philosophy courses for the first time
and there's sort of two extremes that
are equally silly one one extreme solely
in my view anyway one extreme is that
super radical view you know where like
who you are literally changes the
physical truth of the world and the
other is that's must be what you mean to
be claiming if there's any relationship
between who you are and what you know
about the world right and and I think
that so the lesson of all that we're
saying here is that there is a difficult
but good place to be you know in the
middle of these clinics yeah and I know
that that way of phrasing things
actually and I think you're quite right
that that is often how the debate is is
carried out and that way of phrasing
themes actually comes back so we
discussed right at the beginning which
is a thing which I think first off a
whole reflection intensely I want to be
more careful about is separating out
claims about how you know and claims out
what's true and so very often some of
the most heated debate about um about
for instance Tamplin histology people
will attribute to standpoint
epistemologists who are saying who you
are makes a difference to what you know
the claim that you are makes a
difference to what's true and those are
very different claims and there should
be and one of them's that far more
plausible
yeah than the other I mean and so to
speak standpoint epistemologists
are paying a special attention to to
social positions especially social
positions in hierarchies or
relationships of oppression but in some
sense
everyone's going to be a kind of
standpoint of the theorists of montrose
I think presume
having received a PhD in physics puts me
in a better position to understand and
reason but how we know something yeah
exactly
everyone thinks that some life
experiences on an opponent the
standpoint epistemologists are just
drawing attention to a class through
experiences of live being oppressed in
certain kind of ways which they say
makes some different differences in
these areas so so the basic idea behind
standpoint epistemology system ology is
should be sort of no more foreign to you
than saying that you know someone says
that the thumb of the physics PhD does
more than someone about a physics PhD
about whether or not the universe is
expanding they're not claiming that
whether or not the universe expanding
depends on whether you have a visit page
and it's it's the same thing well this
is good because it makes it sound like I
had organization in mind we started
talking as it always makes me look good
even it's just kind of random I believe
it all right leave coffee bright thanks
so much for be on the podcast
thanks a havisham
[Music]
you
[Music]